[Music]
miley cyrus sees
all those headlines about her dating
life and she's shooting them all down
with an
epic mystery makeout it was so awesome
on tuesday the triple threat took to
tick-tock to post
this video
[Music]
that's a 28 year old lip-syncing to a
remixed version of without you by kid
leroy
while a montage of wild headlines about
miley and her dating life
flash in the background
[Music]
and the whole thing ends with miley
puckering up to a mystery man
but i'm scared to be alone
[Music]
of course people have always been pretty
invested in miley's dating life
you actually find someone that you
really click with it's it's really
important
just last month the entertainer and
english singer youngblood
sparked romance rumors after a fun night
out together
in la but a source told et at the time
that the two are quote
not dating adding they are just buddies
and we're having a fun night out with
friends
i make jokes all the time i'm just as
make fun of myself as everyone else does
the former disney star last dated cody
simpson but the two split in august
2020.
i interviewed you and you talked to me
about your friendship
with a certain miss miley cyrus and i'm
just wondering when it went
from more
naturally over time before that she was
romantically linked to caitlyn carter
following her split from her former
husband liam hemsworth
how cool is that to be wife husband and
wife it's the best
it's the best it's um you know i feel so
lucky to be with someone like her and uh
yeah it's great very very very lucky
miley recently opened up about her
dating life tweeting quote
man being single sucks all i ever do is
whatever the [ __ ] i want
yeah so i think it's safe to say miley
is better at social media than
all of us it's just it's really i think
it's fun over the weekend
she posted this tick tock subtly
referencing hannah montana
so this guy i was talking to the other
day was like i'm glad you're not like
one of those girls with different
personalities
are you sure you don't want the best of
both worlds
[Music]
and in march lil na's x playfully
trolled miley with an epic parody of
hannah montana revealing her true
identity as miley stewart
something that happened a lot on the hit
disney show
i can't keep doing this lily i can't
keep living this last stop
stop the music
i'm hannah montana so miley who starred
in the series from 2006 to 2011
did lil nas one better duetting with his
video
playing hannah's best friend lily again
the old hannah reveals losing its shock
value you do this every
week and later that month to celebrate
the 15th anniversary of when hannah
montana first started
miley took to twitter to share this
adorable handwritten note to the tv role
that put her on the map
writing in part quote although you are
considered to be an alter ego
in reality there was a time in my life
when you held more of my identity in
your glovette
than i did in my bare hands and
get this the official twitter account
for hannah montana
responded writing quote nice to hear
from you miley cyrus it's only been a
[Music]
decade